this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace
the glute Bridge might look like a
fairly Naf exercise you're kind of lying
there on the ground impotently thrusting
at the heavens it's nothing like a
movement you might use in the real world
and it doesn't even involve much
resistance but that's really not the
point the glute Bridge instead is a
movement that's all about teaching you
to activate the glutes and building that
all-important mind muscle connection
this can be fantastic for restoring
functional movement for many people and
for tapping into far greater athletic
performance especially if you're someone
who happens to sit a lot
my wife is being very unhelpful off
camera
foreign
by the way if you're wondering why this
is the second video to be filmed from my
home instead of some lovely Scenic spot
it's because I and the rest of my family
have been ill for ages my uvula was
swollen like a slug and sitting across
the back of my tongue it was painful and
disgusting but I imagine you're not here
to hear about my uvula rather you're
here to hear about the glute bridge and
why this exercise is so useful and
something that you should include in
your training and the reason of course
is that many people are quad dominant
that's to say that their glutes have
effectively gone to sleep on them and
during movements like running and
jumping they're actually utilizing
muscles like their quads more than they
should be to compensate for that lack of
strength and control in the glutes and
now for many of us this of course comes
from sitting for large periods of time
during this time your hip flexors are in
a shortened position and can become
tight at the same time you're literally
sitting on your glutes while also having
them in that stretched position many of
us will sit for really long durations
like this for eight or more hours every
single day so is there any wonder that
over time we lose the ability to
properly Engage The glutes this means
that many of us are leaving a huge
amount of our athletic potential on the
table the glutes are not only the
largest muscles in the body it's also
often described as anti-gravity muscle
the muscle that's responsible for
launching you up in the air when you
jump for helping you to climb up stairs
so if you want to run faster jump higher
and be more explosive then you need
strong glutes at the same time this can
also improve your posture because if
you're sitting for a long period of time
and you have those tight hip flexors and
weak glutes what's going to happen is
you're going to have too much force on
the front of your pelvis creating that
anterior pelvic tilt meanwhile you don't
have enough tension at the back to
straighten it back out this results in
an overly Lord dotic lumbar spine that
kind of lower curve and your butt
sticking out what some people
flatteringly call the Donald Duck Butt
not only does this not look particularly
attractive it's also a recipe for injury
and especially if you end up
compensating for stiffness and lack of
strength and control in this area by
rounding the lower back when you should
be using that hip hinge to pick things
up off the ground for example the
glute's also really important for
bracing the core and you see this for
example when performing a freestanding
handstand here you need to really brace
the core to prevent yourself from
extending into that nasty banana Arch
handstand which I do all the time with a
more stable core you can prevent injury
and you can create more proximal
stiffness to increase distal athleticism
it's at this point in the video where I
might normally show some b-roll of maybe
the clouds rolling or some beautiful
tree leaves so instead you can have
maybe some flowers or a rainbow painted
cat
so just train your glutes more right
just start doing some squats problem
solved not so fast there cowboy
the problem is of course you can do as
many heavy squats as you like you can do
as many deadlifts but if you're not
properly engaging the glutes because you
can no longer activate them consciously
then you're not going to be training the
right muscles you're going to be using
other muscles to power through those
movements as a result you're not growing
your glutes you're not building as much
Explosive Performance as you could be
and you're not fixing the problem and
this is where the glute bridge is so
useful because not only is a highly
effective tool for training and
strengthening that mind muscle
connection with the glutes it's also a
great way to see whether you have that
connection whether you're actively using
your glutes through the movements that
you're supposed to be using them for so
let's have a look at what that looks
like
hello so I'm going to show you now how
to perform the glute bridge I'm not
going to go into it in a lot of detail
the first time ideally you should try
this yourself and see where you feel the
tension then afterwards we're going to
look at some fixes to help make sure
you're doing it properly so here's what
you want to do first you're going to lie
down flat on the ground
for sure
thing away you want to bring your feet
to be quite close up to your butter if
you want The Shins to be almost vertical
ideally as you're lifting yourself up
you want to keep your legs straight and
aligned like this not splayed out like
you're in stirrups giving birth and then
you're just going to put your body down
and whilst resting on the ground you're
going to thrust
Your Parts up towards
the Sealy
like I say just do this in the way that
feels natural for now okay now so
ideally we want to be feeling that in
the glutes of course it is called the
glute Bridge after all but you might
find that instead you're feeling it
either in your quads like we say you can
be quite dominant or even in your back
which is kind of even worse what you're
doing is essentially making up for the
lack of utilization of the glutes by
either kicking down towards the ground
to raise yourself up or even just
arching the lower back which we don't
really want to do so we need to train
ourselves to utilize the glutes instead
and we can do this with a few cues and a
few fixes there are many cues that are
commonly recommended to ensure that
you're actually engaging the glutes
during this movement one example is to
drive through the heels maybe even to
elevate your toes off the ground in
other to really focus on thrusting the
hips up to the ceiling I've said
thrusting in this video more than usual
another one is to place something around
the outside of the legs
such as a resistance band
and then to try and drive them outwards
at the same time you'd want one that
offers more resistance ideally
the reason this is effective is it
forces you to engage the gluteus medius
this is a hip abductor it allows you to
move the legs apart if you're looking
for a way to Remember by the way the
difference between abduction and
adduction I like to think adduction is
you're adding the two legs back together
and abduction is that one is being
abducted by an alien and taken away
these tips can be really effective they
helped me early on but what I've found
to be the most useful for me is to
really think about what the role what
the function of the glutes is and that's
to extend the upper leg to rotate the
femur within the socket in other words
you're moving your top of your leg this
way for me thinking about what you're
trying to do with the muscle is a more
useful method because it allows you to
then carry that awareness over into
other activities and actually think
about the what and the why and how you
should be moving and you can assist this
with a little visualization I like to
just imagine that I'm trying to curl my
hamstring to touch the ground nothing
else I'm not trying to curl the whole
leg just the hamstring and when you do
that you have to use your glutes you're
rotating at that point at the same time
you want to try and make sure you're
bracing down with the core creating a
posterior pelvic tilt so if you look at
where your back is normally when you're
on the ground
oh look at that I have to take my top
off if you lie with a neutral spine
then you're gonna have a slight
Gap here you can't see it on mine
because I've got too much
extra flap but what you want to do is
close that out by rounding the lower
back as though you're going to do a
hollow body
and then whilst maintaining that
position
you're going to drive through the glutes
as well and this is going to prevent you
from using that lower back which isn't
what you want to be doing when you're
doing a hip hinge what can really help
here then is to use the glue Bridge as a
warm-up as a way to activate the correct
muscles prior to doing exercises like
squats or deadlifts or kettlebell swings
and then if you just maintain that
awareness of the glutes as you're
performing those movements really asking
yourself is this where I'm feeling it
then you can start to build that
connection stronger so it starts to
happen automatically and at the same
time it builds bigger and more powerful
glutes than you otherwise could have by
just kind of muddling through that
really engaging the correct muscles at
the same time there are plenty of
variations you can use to increase the
difficulty of the standard glute Bridge
of course you can do a legs elevated
glute Bridge you can do a one-legged
glute Bridge which is also a great way
to see if you're stronger on one side or
if you're having trouble activating one
side you can even do an elevated
one-legged glute Bridge you can do a
weighted glute Bridge or you can take a
leaf out of Brett contravis's book and
perform the barbell hip throw here
you're going to be elevating your upper
body on a bench for example and then
laying the barbell across your lap again
before thrusting up again making sure
it's the glutes that you're working from
so in short the barbell hip thrust
allows you to train the glutes at a
greater range of motion and this
translates to movements like sprinting
where you need to go through that
greater range of motion and produce
Force what do you guys think is the
glute Bridge a useful exercise is it one
that you're already using one that you
intend to incorporate into your training
let me know in the comments down below
and also let me know what I've missed
what other exercises like this or
progressions do you also incorporate if
you're looking for a training program
that does include these kinds of
movements designed to help you improve
your functional performance or your
super functional performance then check
out my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 the protein
performance system that comes with an 85
Plus page ebook and over two hours of
instructional video I'll leave a link to
that in the description down below by
the way guys thank you so much for
watching this one and I'll see you next
time
bye for now
I've got nowhere to go I'm in my own
house
by the way today's video was sponsored
by Squarespace Squarespace is a platform
for building websites that makes it
extremely easy for anybody to get
started with their own website with zero
coding skills necessary that said it
also provides a full Suite of tools and
options everything you possibly need to
create a fully functional professional
website I love Squarespace because it
really levels the playing field this way
so that anyone can get started and
create something just as effective as a
much bigger company and thereby get a
fair start so to highlight a few of
those features Squarespace gives you a
really simple and intuitive way to
design your website you can pick from an
existing template or start them from
scratch and they can edit it to your
heart's content with simple drag and
drop features it includes a fully
integrated commenting system with
threaded comments replies and likes it
has member management allowing you to
see and control who's commenting on your
site and visiting publishing posts once
your site is up and running is extremely
easy thanks to publishing tools you can
schedule posts for later you can publish
and write away you can also integrate
social media with a website so you
automatically show feeds from your
social media channels right there on
your home page you can generate Revenue
with members only gated content or take
it one step further and start selling
products from your website using
powerful and comprehensive e-commerce
tools and you can expand these
e-commerce features and any of the other
features endlessly thanks to a huge
selection of plugins that might mean tax
reconciliation global Shipping inventory
management pretty much anything you can
think of head over to squarespace.com if
you want to learn more and when you're
ready to launch your own site head over
to squarespace.com forward slasher
bioneer to get 10 off your first domain
or website thanks once again to
Squarespace for sponsoring this video
thanks so much to you guys for sticking
around till the end and I'll see you
next time bye for now